what the orbital perspective is is a
slightly different way of looking at our
global society of looking at our planet
its perspective that takes a long-term
view it's a perspective that takes a
big-picture view and you know when we
zoom out and see our planet from space a
lot of things become clear not only do
we see where the pieces of the puzzle
fit but who has and what value they add
and I think it's it's a acknowledgment
that we don't have to accept the status
quo on our planet it's a belief that
anything is possible that we through
working together can really tackle the
big problems facing our planet so I've
been very fortunate I've had a lot of
perspective shifting experiences I lived
on the bottom of the ocean for three
weeks in Aquarius the only undersea
laboratory I flew once on the US Space
Shuttle on a two-week construction
mission aboard the International Space
Station and I spent about a half-year
half of 2011 living and working on board
the International Space Station after
launching from Kazakhstan on a Russian
rocket with a couple of Russian
crewmates when it was time to depart the
space station and return home my Russian
crewmates and I climbed into our Soyuz
spacecraft the same one we launched from
five and a half months earlier we
wiggled into our seats and we had our
space suits on we strapped ourselves in
it's really tight it's like three guys
in the back of a trunk you know in the
trunk of a car our knees are in our
chest we undock from the space station
and I had a window I was sitting in the
right seat I don't window right by my
head and I strained as best I could to
see the space station as we were
departing it because I knew quite likely
that would be the last time I ever saw
this this magnificent sight and after we
undocked we did a couple of laps around
around the planet and as we passed the
south tip of south america we fishtail
our spacecraft around the point the
engines backwards and I remember when we
did this I saw this crescent moon go by
the window it was just absolutely
breathtaking
we fired our engines just a little bit
at the precisely the right moment to
have us enter the upper atmosphere and
as we enter the upness of our atmosphere
we started to develop drag you know we
had this fiery violent ride through the
atmosphere it was it was really amazing
once you got down to a lower altitude
the speed really
becomes amazing and I remember seeing no
there goes Africa as we wish by the
continent and the parachutes open they
throw us all over the place
shortly thereafter we smashed into the
ground we bounced we flipped we rolled
over and when we rolled over we rolled
on the right side and now my window was
pointing it at the ground and I remember
looking out of the window
and seeing a rock of flour and a blade
of grass and I remember thinking to
myself distinctly that I'm home and what
was really amazing about that that
thought was that I was in Kazakhstan and
so for me at that moment my home was no
longer Houston Texas where I live with
my family or Yonkers New York where I
was born and grew up my homeless birth
and it was really a perspective shifting
moment for me so one of the big tenets
of the book and and the reason why I
cites and tell so many stories about
people that are accomplishing amazing
things that have never been in space one
of the main tenants is that you don't
have to be in orbit to have the orbital
perspective we don't have to be in space
to realize that we need each other we
don't have to be in space to realize
that by being open to new innovative
partnerships new innovative solutions
answers can come to the challenges we
face from from anywhere in the world and
so I think the big thing is to
understand the framework that we've
built to view the world in now we live
as we all know in a very very
complicated world there's so many
horrors there's terrorism there's
poverty there's there's you know almost
a billion people that don't have access
to clean water there's so many ills that
are our global society face but our
world also has compassion and love and
ingenuity and creativity and
self-sacrifice and so it becomes very
complicated and what we tend to do is
and myself included we tend to build a
more simplified framework through which
to view the world through which to view
our global society and when we do that
we tend to build cubby holes and put
people and groups into certain cubby
holes it may just makes it easier and
more palpable to understand the events
there the current events of the day but
what that does is it also creates
barriers and walls we box ourselves into
these cubby holes which sometimes
prevents us from
dialogue prevents us from recognizing
any merit in the position in another
person's position another groups
position because we've written off whole
groups of people whole countries whole
cultures as not worth our time not worth
our there's no value in the
problem-solving process to engage those
people and I think once we realize that
and we can step outside of it I don't
just mean you know people and
organizations you know there's political
parties you know a good example is the
political process in the u.s. right now
where we've become so divided and to the
point where one side will refuse to
recognize any merit whatsoever in the
position of the other side if they win
we lose if they gain we lose and so I
think that is a recipe for disaster it's
a recipe for not being able to have
progress it's it's a barrier to us being
able to tackle the big problems and so I
think you don't have to go to space to
realize that you don't have to go to
space to realize that each and every one
of us is riding through the universe
together on this spaceship that we call
earth that were on or connected they
were all in this together and that we're
all family and I think one of the big
things that the orbital perspective
teaches us is there are no passengers on
Spaceship Earth we're all crewmates and
as crewmates we have a responsibility to
mine the ship and take care of our
fellow crewmates
you